hey everyone we are now sitting down
with Joe look back from Lynn Grove you
got it and we're gonna be talking about
the importance of bio resins mixed with
bio fibers bio fibers yep plant plant
based materials plant based materials
the importance of plant based materials
and so you were actually teaching me
about the history of this and leading up
to now yeah I thought that was really
interesting what civilizations used to
use to build sales and to build ropes
that was linen yep yeah so before the
era of plastics the era we live in today
or you know let's say steel the
structural material was was essentially
a grown material right and so human
civilization more or less tracks with
the usage of high-performance plant
based materials and we have
archaeological evidence of this of
course but even over ten thousand years
ago you know ancient Egypt they were
using linen from the flax plant they
still grow that today in Egypt for their
sales and for the ropes on their ships
and so that material enabled
international trade so the growth of
civilization and the Romans as well and
so without you could say without these
materials there wouldn't have been human
civilization as we know as a oh yeah and
that's flax linen even back then yep yep
okay even mummies even mummies yes so
back then you know walk us through this
flax plant so it's this big stalk how is
this like a lacuna does it look like a
hemp plant no it does no yeah we're
really trying to say so
so most people know flax today because
of the seeds yes right because they've
become very popular omega-3 and the
seeds are at the top of the plant the
plants actually very beautiful it grows
about three three feet tall the top of
it is a is a pretty flower right and the
seeds come from the top
our fiber is in the middle of the stock
it's actually called a based fiber in
the middle and so I'll give you this
outside is no the outside is is kind of
like the hay right it's the Shive we
remove the outside we have to strip the
outside in the inside is this amazing
fiber right and that's what we're
looking for there are other there are
other plants that that are in this class
of materials they're called based fibers
and and hemp is one of them we picked
flax because it actually has the highest
stiffness to weight of any of the
different textiles from plants in fact
it's like aerospace grade strength so
that's that's why we initially picked it
it also happens and it's very rare that
to have more than just that but it
happens that it's also co2 negative and
requires no irrigation right and it
grows in 100 days negative co2 negative
and requires no irrigation and it grows
in a hundred day though irrigation
correct so not you know beyond replacing
wood which is what Lynn Grove is about
and we'll get to that my jacket here is
made out of out of linen and you know if
someone wants to be more eco-friendly
just pick linen over cotton and you're
already doing something to help yeah
okay that's a good point pickle in
andover con that's a good starting point
and then furthermore is this this is
this plant we didn't we know we knew
about this plan for so long but it's
hilarious that we just forgot about its
usefulness you said no irrigation grows
in a hundred days yep and then we're we
take this Center and how was the center
use how is it as strongest
aerospace-grade
and how can it be replaced how can
replace wood that's so cool yeah well I
mean you know Nature has a lot of our
solutions right right so when we looked
at this we actually were looking
initially to replace old growth wood
right what we found we were doing you
know working with carbon fiber and this
was actually over what 10 years ago now
making guitars of all things using
carbon fiber and we got a lot of
feedback saying give us something that
sounds looks and feels like
would and so we started to benchmark
against old growth its Bruce and what we
realized is ogres groups beat the carbon
fiber that we were working with it was
lighter and stiffer than the samples we
were using at the time right
and that's because all gross Bruce has
the stiffness to weight of steel right
and the linen fiber actually beats that
so it's just a matter of how stiff the
material is for its weight so in this
case the material is so light that the
stiffness to its weight is exceptional
it's because it's so light that's how it
works and the way you know to get a
little obscure the weight composites
work is that the fiber and the resin
come together and it's the fiber that
makes the part super strong yeah and
it's not just any fiber but long fibers
just like yeah wood all right just think
of wood is long fibers and resin the
resin is the lignin in this case we have
stronger fibers and stronger resin and
so if a tree can grow hundreds of feet
tall then our material can grow hundreds
of feet beyond that okay so we have the
resin mixed with these super strong
because the super lightweight but super
strong right fibers okay and then that's
this flax linen and now it's are you
guys already testing in for like selling
wood and selling aerospace parts that
kind of stuff well as you can imagine we
have to be testing for a while to prove
out these things and so we have been
selling in the sports industry where
stiffness to weight is tantamount right
so we have make baseball bats baseball
bats would be a good one yeah everyone
has a reference point right for me it's
mountain biking it's like yeah I did
start rain the frame yeah oh that's cool
right so replacing you know some carbon
fiber with our material you don't have
any mechanical disadvantages but you
have interesting advantages like
vibration damping because it's low
density lighter than carbon fiber means
it absorbs vibration so today we're on
the market
working with fly rod companies fly
fishing
which is incredibly lightweight carbon
fiber or fiberglass and we've replaced
at least some layers of that fishing rod
fishing rods yep
you wouldn't think but those are you
know they weigh nothing yeah arrows like
bow and arrow again super high
performance application stiffness to
weight is everything paddles and board
sports and so we've identified those
markets as great test markets because it
shows that the material is very strong
yes they care about beauty they care
about eco even and so we can give them
like a would like aesthetic right where
they're used to fiberglass or carbon and
for the first time they can have would
feel would look and without any
disadvantages from mechanicals that's so
cool so now you're in what is this like
a dozen different about five so this is
our way of getting out to the market
proving out interest showing this thing
is real even in you know applications
that no one would ever expect to see
something that looks like wood and you
are you selling the flax linen or are
you selling the resin with it as well we
sell it together mixed in and mixed in
and that's the composite and that's what
Eco is yeah that's what right what is
koa iko iko is our Matata yeah yeah yeah
so when we say we see a world that is
built from fast-growing plants that that
is what Ecola represents yeah right it's
it's a adorable products it's a
beautiful product and so if we can
generate demand just innately for
something because it you know someone
looks at it I want that thing then if it
happens to be co2 negative grain but
people will want it for that basic does
this work really well does this improve
my experience of whatever I'm doing
that's what we're after and then there's
the resin made of the resin is bio-based
and so depending on the application it
can come from biomass right or it can
come from like waste from the forest
industry and so we typically try to use
way
product in our bio formulations because
if you use virgin plastic or if you use
virgin biomaterials then you could be
replacing edible crops right that does
not that doesn't help so you know I
don't want to throw anyone on their bus
but a lot of a lot of this sort of
compostable plastics are typically from
corn and corn you know could be grown
for food or it can be grown for plastics
and we prefer to use things that are not
grown for food because that does not
that's a compromise we're looking for
the non compromise solution with resins
that's where a lot of our research goes
we have an LCA person on staff lifecycle
analysis person yeah on staff because
because there's there's you know
ultimately if we have a compromise
product then we're shooting ourselves in
the foot you know we're not going to
make the change we're trying to do in
the world
yeah the resins we're trying to source
it from sustainable sources the resin
there are sources animals they are yeah
and recyclable they do it recyclable and
non-food based a non-food base okay and
then then that mix together with flax
linen that is grown where are you guys
growing right now most of the flax we
use today is sort of the high end stuff
and it comes from Europe
really yeah most of the flax in the
world is grown in Canada yeah for the
seeds okay about a million tons a year
and they throw away the stock so in the
future we see our supply chain coming
from yeah thrown away stocks where we
extract the fibers you just gonna go she
like gonna negotiate that right away
we're working on it yeah this is catch
one
Saskatchewan we're coming for you you're
coming they are coming yeah yeah we're
actually working we're already working
with some folks okay good yeah okay and
that just shows what's out there I mean
one can make structural the chose an
entire sky scape or using plant-based
materials yes they come from the waste
stream and then there's also mycelium as
well so we can actually use that as
structural material can we maybe use
that alongside
flax weekend yep Oh that'd be so
interesting a sample today in our
workshop have you tried with we have two
works we yeah we're we're working with
some of those companies today so
fascinating our main idea that I think
is important to mention we're an
early-stage company right
and so early-stage companies oh we have
this big idea we're gonna we're gonna
cover the world I mean that's what I
said we're gonna cover the world
plant-based most resorts term steps oh
really yeah we're not in the lab here
yeah we want to scale very quickly and
so we're using textile technologies
we're not using beakers correctly and
fermenter which is so interesting
because it almost everybody else is
making molecules are using Peters and I
think that's sexy because they're
inventing something new like it's like
they're really creating something from
scratch we have our proprietary resins
we have knowledge because we took more
products to market using these materials
but we want to work with partners that
allow us to scale unfettered I'll let
you build my house using box linen great
yeah we're we're already in pilots
modular homes yeah oh wow yeah so
they're already doing it well we're you
know we want to be out there and yeah
yeah be getting that feedback from
customers and saying we need this we
need that because you know it's one
thing to do something in the lab it's
another thing when you get out there and
and you know know is it for
waterproofing waterproofing is a really
important step yeah and we actually
include that in our product itself cool
so the net water just slides off rather
than yeah you want to seal it so this
this material this flax linen is lighter
than carbon fiber right yeah so the
closer you get to the lower density
materials are typically hydro scopic
they absorb moisture that's how it works
right
so the light or something gets the more
water absorbs that's basic physics and
so part of the thing that we figure it
out like you you know you're getting at
is well at the end of the day how do you
actually make something out of it well
you you can make something beautiful but
if it absorbs water you lose right great
you know it dies after a couple years we
want something to last for generations
if that's what it was designed for right
yep so again my analogy is old growth
wood at San Francisco where we are today
is built from old-growth redwood write a
material gone forever and everyone that
can afford a building made out of old
growth redwood wants that because that's
a more durable you know bug resistant
rot resistant stronger those houses
stand up they stand the test of time
earthquake resistant as well but I may
not apply to everyone that's that is
what we're gunning for now we've
actually superseded that already awesome
and so making sure that the water
doesn't get absorbed on the fascia layer
the outside layer is a critical part of
what we figured out great and they're
not a sunlight damage and then again fog
or other moisture forms and bugs and
insects etc all that yeah bugs are not a
problem UV UV is also important to have
a facial air and that exterior layer and
so we can take care of UV and moisture
resistance with the same thing you know
yeah and that you know it's it's the
reality on the ground where things
actually work or they fail and it's such
an obvious thing but the idea is you
start with the end what is the actual
usage of this thing and then you work
back from that and we've had the benefit
of that because we put a product to
market on the market a guitar which
people should fit so you know they're
they're sweating all over this thing
right they're playing the heck out of
there taking it all over the world and
so we learn the hard way and bake that
back into the product and now when we
work with the car manufacturer
transportation folks right they're gonna
go through the battery of the tests and
we have to be ready for that and we are
now is it because you're saying
aerospace this lot so it's lighter and
more durable than carbon fiber so
durability is a tough thing that's
strength carbon fiber has more tensile
strength tensile yeah so that's like
yeah pulling apart exactly
but when carbon fiber fails it fails
catastrophically because it's enough it
snaps and what about you our materials
what's called viscoelastic so it bends
before it breaks actually can bend up to
180 degree
that's partially because it slowed se
and it's just the the rep the fibers can
slide apart and Bend and they don't just
stop and so you know yeah we wait all
the way all the way the resin becomes
very important and that's in that
scenario if the resin is brittle it can
be flexible it has to be flexible and so
there are plenty of residents that can
do that too it depends on the
application and we do have basic
formulation customizability right so if
a end customer wants brittle some do
then we can provide that and the resin
if they want flexibility it's a
different resident you can't necessarily
get all the same thing in the same exact
yeah but we can make bespoke materials
our our main product today is on the
aerospace side a structural bio-based
resin with the linen fiber and so that's
that's a pretty high stiffness
formulation but the materials were
developing for for the furniture
industry for instance is with
thermoplastics you know you heat secure
you heat them up you mold it in one
minute and then you let it cool down and
you have your new shape it's like a
candle wax is this thermoplastic is a
good example those materials typically
are much more flexible so they can bend
a lot more so if a customer's big enough
they can drive a custom solution for
their products so for the first time you
can have hey here's a material looks
like wood plugs right into what you
doing and that's pretty exciting because
that means we can go into lots of
different applications ya know and push
sustainability forward is there is there
something else about this that we should
be aware of that you want each
interesting yeah I mean let's see well I
guess the the form of this I mean we
talked about flax fibers and resins it
can be hard to envision what the thing
actually is and so today our eco a
material comes on rolls in various
thicknesses about a hundred yards long
and so the way you work with it is you
you cut out pieces of that you layer it
if needed put it in a mold heat it up
and form a shape
right that's one way and the other way
we offer it is as a structural panel and
that means and this is what's really
interesting you brought up mycelium
mycelium would be used as what's called
a core structure I think other than
plant based composites as kind of the
future material the material of the
future you know our way for us to see a
path forward with our with our
structures that doesn't send us into you
know self-destruction is structural
panels because they are very very light
and stiff the way they work is you have
a skin on the top a skin on the bottom
and a low-density material in the middle
that's a structural panel the farther
the skins get apart the stiffer the
structure gets cubed as long as this the
core is very lightweight you have a
material that it blows every material
out of the water and so when we talk
about over ten times the tensile
strength over six times the stiffness to
weight ratio compared with wood and four
times compared with steel we're talking
about in many cases sandwich panels and
so that's a really important version of
our materials as a sandwich panel
imagine a panel four by eight sheet you
know people will buy go to the local
Home Depot they buy plywood you know the
thing is it weighs you know 20 pounds
ours would weigh a fourth of that and
that can make a huge difference and when
building a house it's stronger and
stronger and stronger it depends on the
width it depends on the skins but you
can certainly make it stronger so the
wider it gets the more I get it gets
stronger and so imagine we want you in
Home Depot then next that's part of our
dream yeah I mean it's they call it in
construction they call it structural
insulated panel right the panel is the
insulation and the structure of the
entire house that's great and it's built
as a skin a structural skin yeah I know
that actually cuts on all the other
costs that are needed for insulation
then yeah it is the insulation is the
structure I mean I think you guys are
science oriented right and so I tend to
avoid this example when you know we're
talking to the industrial or just
regular folks but when you think about
composites that's more like an
exoskeleton right so the exoskeleton of
an insect is the structure of the insect
yeah versus the way we're built and we
all know the insects are built better
than we're built as far as structural
design and so composites are we're
building the structural skin that
structural skin can have a core or it
can be solid but ultimately it's the
skin that makes that the object the
structure stronger yeah and that's how
that's how composites work and we're
we're taking this esoteric world of
composites we're blending it with plant
based materials and we're creating
something new that both is desirable and
like accessible to the customer right
because fiberglass and carbon fiber
they're not really mass-producible mass
marketable kind of materials they don't
have a materiality that people can
relate to other than Motorhead's for
carbon fiber and so this is a
materiality that people can relate to
because it's evocative of wood but it
has those benefits of composites so
we're like popularizing this obscure
world of composites yeah for the rest of
us yeah
thank you so much my pleasure bro of
such a pleasure thank you so much thanks
for your Neverland yeah it's been a
pleasure awesome and where can we find
you online
WWL in Grove comm Lynn Grove comm you
heard it here at indie bio demo day
thank you so much for coming on this has
been a blast and I'll send you the link
later awesome